in one moment everything changed
a russian cruise missile piercing the
heart of ukraine's second city
[Music]
carnage
chaos
and inevitable casualties
they hunt for survivors in the wreckage
of the local government building
[Music]
carefully carrying away the dead
there is a lot of damage there are
killed and wounded a lot of them
this place was renamed freedom square
after ukraine regained its independence
from the soviet union
now it symbolizes the threat this
country's freedom once again faces
no longer clean shaven ukraine's wartime
president addressed eu politicians
his desire to join the block and their
desire to welcome him unbowed by
russia's pressure not to we are fighting
for our rights
for our freedoms
for life for our life and now
but what a price ukraine is paying
a tv station in the capital struck while
miles of russian armor masses around the
outskirts caught in the crossfire are
families like sophia's
she and her three children take shelter
in the basement of their apartment block
whenever there's danger how has it
affected your children this situation
well my middle child mark he is
probably
the one who has reacted
who's been hurt the most
because he can't really understand
that's been the hardest on him my
daughter she's older she's just grown
uh older in a day in a minute and how
are you finding things at the moment
it's a bit hard well
the hard thing
the only hard thing
for me
right now is
to
make my breath my brother
understand that
the war still has a way to run as
civilians too vent their fury
this footage taken in the coastal city
of malitopol
defiance but also much more danger in
the days ahead
debra haynes sky news kiev